(upbeat music)
- Welcome to your Weekend Ticket.
First we'll check out who came out on top
in last weekend's box office numbers.
Then, we'll let you know what's new
in theaters this weekend.
And, finally we'll leave
you with some new releases
to stream on FandangoNOW.
(upbeat music)
"Sonic the Hedgehog"
doesn't just gotta go fast,
it's gotta break records.
The family friendly film had
the largest debut weekend ever
for video game adaptation,
coming in with $58 million
over the traditional weekend,
to last year's best of $54
million from "Detective Pikachu."
"Sonic the Hedgehog" totaled $70 million
over President's Day, four-day weekend,
making it the fourth highest
President's Day weekend
of all time.
That's a lot of rings.
Speaking of breaking records,
last weekend's other new wide
release "Fantasy Island,"
a PG-13 update of the classic TV show
with an added Blumhouse
horror horror twist
became the highest
grossing horror film debut
of this year so far,
at $14 million after President's Day.
And from presidents to the
current king of social media,
Bong Joon Ho's "Parasite" walked away
with four Oscars the previous weekend,
including becoming the
first-ever foreign language film
to win best picture.
"Parasite" also returned
to 2,000 theaters,
added $6.8 million to
its total box office,
and had a 234% increase in ticket sales.
This marks the largest post-Oscars boost
for a best picture winner
in the past decade.
The South Korean film entered the top ten
for the weekend,
and became the fourth highest
grossing foreign language film
of all time in the U.S. at $45 million
and pushed its total gross
over $205 million worldwide.
(upbeat music)
- [Doll] To live again he needed a friend.
- The first new movie
heading theaters this weekend
is a horror movie sequel
called "Brahms: the Boy two."
This time around it's a
new story and a new cast,
but the same same director
and the same old creepy,
well-dressed doll.
When a family with a troubled
son moves into the guesthouse
of Hillshire mansion from the first movie,
it isn't long before they find Brahms.
The son quickly becomes
eerily bonded to the doll
who seems to have upped
his creepy abilities.
Sorry, Katie Holmes.
Like I said, director
William Brent Bell returns
as does the writer of the
first movie Stacey Menear.
So, if you liked the first movie,
you'll probably want to catch this one.
(barks)
- I'm glad you're enjoying yourself.
(water rushing)
- "The Call of the Wild"
also comes out this weekend.
In this film adaptation
of the popular novel,
Harrison Ford teams up with
a hairy co-pilot once again,
this time it's a tortured
sled dog named Buck.
After Buck is ripped from his home,
sold as a sled dog, and
endures mistreatment,
he eventually meets John Thornton,
and the two set off on
adventures in the wild,
testing their strength and bond.
The novel is told from
Buck's point of view
and it looks like the film is staying true
to giving him a lot of personality.
The CG Buck is a scan of
a real life dog adopted
by the director and his
motion capture is acted
by human, Terry Notary,
who also did the mo-cap
for Kong in Kong: Scull Island.
Also, director Chris
Sanders has writing credits
on several movies you're
probably familiar with.
Like "Aladdin," "Mulan,"
"Lilo and Stitch,"
"How to Train Your Dragon,"
and "Beauty and the Beast,"
just to name a few.
(upbeat music)
There's also some great
movies that are now available
to stream at home on FandangoNOW.
Let's start with Oscar
winner Jojo Rabbit.
Taika Waititi won his first Oscar
for best adapted screenplay with this film
about a young kid growing up
in Germany during World War two.
"Jojo Rabbit" is a satire that
follows a lonely, German boy
named Jojo, played by Roman Griffin Davis,
who idolizes Hitler and Nazis.
But, he finds that his
loyalties are tested
when he learns his mother
is hiding a Jewish girl
in his house.
The film stars Scarlett Johansson,
newcomer Roman Griffin
Davis, Sam Rockwell,
and writer, director
Taika Waititi as Hitler.
As of this filming, the movie sits
at an 80% certified fresh
and an audience review score
of 95%, 'cause who doesn't
love Taika Waititi?
No one.
No one doesn't like Taika Waititi.
Now available to stream,
the Oscar nominated "Beautiful
Day in the Neighborhood."
While not a biopic on the life
of the lovable Fred
Rogers, this movie is based
on a real life story.
The films tells the story
about the reporter whose life
is touched by Mr. Rogers,
as he learns more about the
man and his positive impact
on the world around him.
Tom Hanks of course plays Fred Rogers
and was given blessing and
praise from Mr. Rogers widow,
Joanne Rogers for his portrayal.
And, if afterwards you want
a deeper biographical look
into Mr. Fred Rogers heartwarming life,
I recommend "Won't You Be My Neighbor."
Also available for digital
purchase on FandangoNOW.
There's so much Mr. Rogers.
That's your weekend ticket.
Leave us a comment below
and let us know what you'll
be watching this weekend.
I'm Khail Anonymous and
I'll see you next Tuesday
with more box office
numbers, new releases,
and new movies available to
stream at home on Fandango Now.
(light, upbeat music)